tu m'avais dit 16h et 18h quand j'ai
prolongé parce qu'ils s'éclatent et que
ce soir pas de dépassement quand kraft
kutwa 4 heures 3 heures tiberi hockey
junior s'est très bien passé ça ah mais
oui oui oui
christine kristin de berlin et londres
de londres voilà c'est ça of course
c'est cool de voir ni avec mon bébé
c'est ainsi qu'est ce que tu les connais
c'est de la bombe
acm couchent ensemble mais franchement
pas assez pour ghabat chabab voilà c'est
officiel ce barman ou je pense que tu te
rendras l'enfance comme ces plans vont
rester une carte d'embarquement et
passent pas la copine à l'abri cet
embarquement il passe pas mais donc tu
connais qu'une phrase toi j'ai un bébé
sur les bras je trouve pas sa mère j'ai
tout perdu mon portefeuille que j'ai pu
te coucher une peu comme parler français
ouais ça m'arrive à vous allez me sauver
la vie avec plaisir on n'est pas à peu
près là c'est pas fou c'est le changer
la vie il ya mes coordonnées pro et ça
c'est perso
tous les duels avez vous la moindre idée
des conséquences et votre éducation sur
gloria
la semaine dernière n'est pas venu de
tous ah bon même pas le lundi par est
d'envoyer des faux mails et tu dis la
vérité à ta fille un matin elle va se
rendre compte que cuilleron depuis des
années et ce à quoi moi ça va réellement
la rendre malheureuse ça a duré huit ans
tu sais ce que c'est huit ans s'est
invitée faut qu'elle rentre à la maison
et tout soit comme avant ça ne va pas
être exactement comme avant
elle est venue pour [ __ ] la merde dans
la famille c'est pas la peine j'ai pas
envie de leur rendre malheureuse tu peux
entendre ça lorient est arrivé dans ma
vie du jour au lendemain je n'étais pas
prêt
je fais du mieux que j'ai pu
je te laisserai plus jamais te promets
mais parvenir là
et suis juste un peu de temps au départ